i have a question for you
how would you have coped with the clovid
19 pandemic if you'd had no access to
the internet
march 2020
i know we all want to forget but allow
me to take you back to march 2020.
you see it felt like one minute we were
doing what we always do going about our
daily business
and then we were keeping sort of one eye
on a virus that was over
there
and then the next day boom we were in a
head-on collision with a pandemic that
nobody knew what to do about
authorities jumped to action
don't go to church don't go to the
mosque don't see your friends don't go
to restaurants don't go outside don't
use public transport and don't visit
your parents don't go to school don't go
to work it was a barrage of don'ts from
every direction possible
it was a lot
but we adapted
we started to accept
and slowly we shifted more and more of
what we did from in person to online
we started to rely on the power of the
internet to order our groceries online
to order our meals
to speak to our friends
or even to learn how to take care of
that plan finally
we used the internet to pray we used it
to exercise to meditate to speak to our
therapists
organizations including the one that i
work with
shifted to remote working and i was able
to continue working some schools figured
out how to deliver online classes and my
children only had three weeks of
interruption to their learning before
they were back in class online
granted they were in these classes
wearing a school shirt and a school tie
with pajama bottoms
but i couldn't do anything about it
because i was doing pretty much the same
thing in my zoom meetings
unfortunately this picture that i've
painted was not the same for everyone
it certainly wasn't true for those
without access to the internet
the lady who helps us with our chores in
the house
talked to me about her rising levels of
anxiety as she saw more and more of her
friends lose their jobs
her friends who sold in markets who sold
at street corners they had no customers
and therefore no monies because we were
all sheltering in place
while she saw my children sitting in
their zone classes talking to their
teachers her own children had to be
taken to the village because you see
with all the parents out trying to make
some money and no school for the kids to
go to
their safety and security was no longer
guaranteed so the village was their only
option
in my own home village of casama in
rural zambia a beautiful and brilliant
young girl named chamba faces the exact
same fate of not being able to continue
her education
because you see they don't have access
to the internet
and the longer the pandemic rages on
the further and further and further away
her dream of becoming a medical doctor
go
and the higher her chances become of
becoming a teenage mom or getting
married off as a teenager
many of us use the internet for so many
things
even if it was just talking to our
parents on video calls and we did so
without a second thought to those
without internet
did it ever cross your mind how they
those without internet were coping
we live in a digital age where access to
the internet is no longer a nice to have
it is a definite must-have
the internet provides a tool for us to
engage in democratic conversations we
have a voice in spaces that were
previously a preserve of the few whereas
before only those who could go to tv
stations radio stations and have access
to newspaper interviews had to say
now everybody can speak about issues
that affect them
just in the last few years we have seen
the power of the internet used to
connect people from across the world
people who don't even speak each other's
languages have been able to rally
together to fight against things like
racism sexism climate change and so much
more
and globally over 2 billion people did
not have access to the internet 2
billion
so why should that number of 2 billion
people concern you
as i mentioned the internet gives power
to people to contribute to their
economies to contribute to politics and
to social issues
let me put the economic contribution
into context my home country of zambia
relies on agriculture we place a lot of
emphasis on agriculture and rightly so
because 60
of the zambian population relies on
agriculture for their livelihoods that's
according to the united nations
statistics
and yet when we look at the numbers
agriculture contributes only 7.5 to the
country's gdp in most years
so sixty percent of the population is
relying
on something that contributes 7.5
percent to the gdp
in contrast data from 2019 showed that
one developed nation
was able to get 10 percent of its gdp
contribution from the power of the
internet not technology more broadly the
internet
can you imagine what would happen if
more people had access to the internet
unless we forget
access to the internet would give
chamber in my home village
the right to learn she would be able to
go to school and get closer to realizing
her dream of contributing to the health
sector
we need to act now
we need to actively and collectively
ensure that going forward everyone has
access to a free fair and feminist
internet
we cannot afford to look away simply
because we are comfortable and we have
access because we need the contribution
of the two billion we need them
contributing to the economies of our
countries we need their voices in
politics we need their voices on social
issues
now i'll be the first to admit that this
is not a small task what i'm proposing
an equitable internet
is a major undertaking but we have to
start somewhere
we need governments and development
partners to start to acknowledge that
digital rights in a digital era are
important to every citizen of their
countries policies that encourage
competition among technology providers
regulation that allows for low-cost
energy solutions to penetrate even where
it's hard to reach changes to school
curricula to include digital literacy
and free internet to the lowest income
citizens all those are just a starting
point
but we also understand that with the
world's economy slowing down most of our
governments will not prioritize digital
access
most of them will default to the
traditional election winners
those infrastructure projects that are
outdated before they even completed
they will focus on those and those
projects only benefit the middle class
and the upper class
leaving the poira even further behind
but this is where the private sector
non-profits and foundations come in they
certainly have the technical skills the
expertise and the financial resources to
ensure that every citizen has access to
the internet
and we need staff holding global
corporations to account in 2020 we
learned that at least 20 developing
countries were missing out on as much as
2.8 billion dollars in tax revenue from
just three big tech companies three
this is only a tip of the iceberg
because we know there are a lot of
companies operating in these locations
but due to unfair global tax rules
they're not giving back their fair share
we need to demand that they start to
give back and give back in a way that is
sustainable that is genuine and does not
come with the conditions that they
normally attach to anything that they
consider free in these contexts
and to ensure sustainability it can be
as simple as starting to look at what
has already been tested in terms of
providing access to technologies
bringing those up to the surface and
then working with communities to make
sure that whatever is put in place is
for the long term and not just for the
immediate
one thing we can all agree on is that
are definitely enough internet resources
to go around and the technology is
certainly advanced enough to make sure
that everybody has access
we need to figure out how we bring these
resources together so that chamber in my
village does not just have access to
learning content that is relevant to her
but that she's also able to take part in
economic discussions in political
discourse and making sure that she has
access to an internet where she is
protected from online abuses such as
surveillance intimidation and bullying
on individual level you and i those of
us with access need to stand with those
that don't have we need to make sure
that we are not leaving those two
billion behind and that we're making
sure they have access to all the tools
they need to live up to their full
potential
so knowing how an equitable internet
benefits the collective
how will you contribute to reducing that
two billion number